tonight on Kitchen Nightmares walk in
the [__] are we doing Gordon heads to
the town of Beaver Pennsylvania and
finds a brother and sister at War what's
the problem with the Russians he is and
while they play the blame game he points
the finger at me it's always my fault
they are quickly destroying their
father's restaurant here I'm here every
day you're not here every day to make
matters worse the dad is completely
unaware of how bad the problems really
are those two need to know how bad
they've become the dining room is filthy
disgusting the food is repulsive looks
like curdled milk and the kitchen is a
health hazard see them all around the
sides you serving rotten Foods it's
clear that this brother and sister are
more focused on their anger and
resentment toward each other should dad
know that you're this bad then running
their father's restaurant you should be
ashamed
tonight oh my gosh these disgusting pigs
get ready for the one Kitchen Nightmares
I'm not gonna continue that work at all
come crashing down I'm stopping you
looking more stupid before it even
starts shut this down
what is that you certainly rotten food
personally kill them then wake up you
wake up shut the place down here
[Music]
Pennsylvania an upper middle class
suburban community located 28 miles
outside of Pittsburgh and home to
levante's Italian restaurant opened in
1998 by Dino fratton jelly
hello
after graduating college Dino wanted to
open a restaurant
and with his father Tony investing his
life savings Dino's Dream came true you
starting to get orders when we opened
there wasn't much down here and the town
had a need for a restaurant cajun
chicken and broccoli and it's a little
overwhelmed with how much business we
had the fun hasn't begun yet so I asked
my sister to come in and help me out
okay there's eight of you
at the time I had a flower shop I was a
florist but I felt like I needed to help
Dino so I sold my flower shop and came
to work here at levantes and joy we'll
be right with you everything was going
fine and then unfortunately we got
competition that changed everything
how many tables you each have two
and Dino Janae what's our special
tonight pasta spinachi
those are special all the time
you know has absolutely no clue what
he's doing in the kitchen
are you kidding
I'm gonna let you do this the quality of
the food is gross it's definitely chewy
they're like rubber when are we opening
guys Tina I would replace her with a
manager who knew what she was doing
[Music]
are you kidding me she's a disaster
figure it out one of the most
frustrating things is just the fact that
Dean and Dino cannot function together
it's just so simple
I listen to her little brother very
often
way street you've done nothing that I've
asked you to do as a general manager
that's not true he points the finger at
me everything it's always my fault do
you know Dina all right all right
Dino and my relationship gotten worse
and Dino walked away for about a year
and a half and left the whole business
on my shoulders this is too hard in the
middle and then tried to come back it
just kept declining
our situation is pretty desperate right
now we owe 1200. do they have a 10-day
grace period no they're not even being
patient anymore
up to so much money it is inside this
restaurant if this restaurant closes
I'll be at a quarter of a million
dollars
just don't know what happens
I feel really bad for Tony because I
don't think that he really even knows
like how bad it is Tina and Dino are
basically throwing his money away this
place is disaster honestly if Chef
Ramsay was not coming I would give it
six months to live and or just board it
up
[Music]
as Jeff Ramsay makes the short drive in
from the Pittsburgh airport he takes one
more look at the video message that
convinced him to come to levantes
I'm calling out for help my brother and
I have owned for 14 years we have a lot
of bitter arguments over this and
hopefully you can come help us to get
our restaurant back
I really need your help
wow
[Music]
hello hello how are you I know you I
recognize you how are you nice to meet
you good to see you it's a pleasure um
thank you for that message
um I didn't realize things were that bad
but yes personally how are you doing I'm
okay okay you sure I'm ready for your
help okay
um where's brother where is he probably
in the back okay let's sit down have a
chat shall we please making that a phone
call
for Chef Ramsay was just my last hope
I just really need the help
[Music]
how are you Dino Dino good to see you
take a seat uh right good to see you
both good to see you give me a little
insights behind the scenes when did you
open uh we opened in 1998 right I had uh
just graduated college and I was kind of
trying to find my my way in life and me
and my father uh kind of got together
and he was my financial backer so Dad
pulled the Russian for you yeah wow so
you started business together actually
he wanted to start the business and ask
me to come along with him at the time I
had a flower shop so why would you leave
the flower shop I thought
I needed to help you know I thought it
was the right thing so you've given up a
lot to keep this business afloat yes
and where does your father sit in this
throughout the years he's put his money
into it
how much longer can your father
supported financially and I was thinking
how much longer
what's the problem with the Russians
he is
that's they're insane that isn't that's
the truth
who's in charge him he says he is
but I'm here more often than here uh I
wouldn't say that she's here more than
me Chef I've been here in double
probably what she's been here no she
left me yeah there's a reason why I left
oh you left the restrooms I I took my
time away from the restaurant for a
couple years a couple of years
the situation between me and her just
started really dissolving
and I kind of decided to take a little
Hiatus and why would you take time out I
left because I didn't want to lose my
sister forever because I was getting to
that point that I would hate her and
Tina give you an insights to what
happened when dinner left what what
happened to the restrooms I mean I was
here as much as I needed to be how many
hours a week can you answer that
she said she was here all the time it
was 25 hours a week no I'm here you're
not here when was the last night you
worked it doesn't matter I'm here two
months not in the morning till four in
the afternoon you're not here till four
o'clock okay can't you you're the one in
front of the house I'm here every day
I'm here for the last six months you've
been here every 10 months and and I was
here every day I lived here for 10 years
you cannot open the restaurant without
me
could I mean I did in the beginning I
just haven't done it for several years
Chef I've tried Chef he's down here out
there in that doorway and he does this
to me
when I've been working and calling me at
the same time in the same building and I
said right there like walk out and talk
I was like crazy I'm just trying to get
a hold of you now I'm dirty and I don't
like coming out here with dirty clothes
I don't like my clothes to be out here
okay so I'm gonna run upstairs when I
can just motion to you to come back here
that's just Insanity
that drives you crazy there's a problem
with something maybe someone's stable
maybe a question yeah I just thinking do
you want me to scream it across the room
for the Tina can you come over here no I
mean seriously you're upset at me
because of that I can't because now he
won't walk in this dining room we don't
even argue because we don't talk long
enough to argue because you're not here
[Music]
coming up strange Chef Ramsay comes face
to face with some of the worst foods
he's ever seen gross and later what in
the hell an unbelievable kitchen
investigation you serving rotten Foods
threatens the future of levantes I am
stopping the owners serving this
disgusting mess
within minutes of arriving at labonte's
Chef Ramsay has witnessed how
destructive this restaurant has been on
this brother and sister relationship
now it's time to find out if the food is
suffering as well
how are you I'm really how are you good
I'm Sam nice to meet you I was going to
see you a happy smiley face for once
I met the owners earlier and they were
down and in the dumps are they always
like that yes that's and always
okay let's order okay
gotta go for the stuffed uh banana
peppers um I've got to try that Italian
stuffed filet okay how do you like it
done medium rare please okay um Carletta
it's our signature sauce and who came up
with that idea Dino do you know it came
to him in a dream really
our claim to fame came in a Dream from
someone who knows nothing about food or
how to prepare it flip an egg okay
um gotta go for the chicken Coletta
because that's the sauce that was
dreamed of one night in his dream
absolutely thank you very much
absolutely
figgins
don't sweat the chef who would you guys
normally do
[Music]
what is that all of them yeah but it
doesn't taste like olive oil do you want
to buy a little taste
it's very watery
it tastes like fine it does excuse me so
is that Latino nearby yeah absolutely
thank you
wow that's Dreadful Tina shoved Ramsey's
asking for you at 43. uh
Tina's been such a hands-off manager for
so many years now that she's become so
blase yes sir and what is that olive oil
there is that canola oil no it's fully
Thomas
is that the is that what you're serving
there
that mix look at that
geez it smells off you smell that what's
in there I don't know what was the last
time they were cleaned
I don't know
you're the front of house
what a mess there's a bathroom nearby
yeah
[__] what happened there what's that
tiramisu oh my God are they done every
day
probably a couple weeks ago what is that
a fake tumor suit that's a real tune oh
come on no this so that's just sat there
from fresh and you said two weeks no
probably three weeks ago that is longer
than three weeks
foreign
[Music]
excellent thank you you're welcome
thank you
what a mess I asked for mid-rare but
it's cool
it's almost like you've got to stick
your knife in it too
kill it I mean the thing's still [__]
moving
um Sam who I'm trying to cut into that I
also made rare but it's like raw a
little raw is that steak Frozen probably
could you just check with the chef yes
oh
was that steak Frozen he wants to know I
don't was this Frozen yeah yeah okay
well he said it's raw
know if I should laugh or cry which one
always crumbs why is everything so dirty
here there's crap everywhere I mean just
crumbs and hairs and disgusting uh
patina
how often is the restroom cleaned I know
you've got your dates wrong with the
dehydrated desserts we do our own
cleaning you do your own cleaning I I
appreciate that
that's not what I asked how often is
Russian cleaned
how often
um
I can't answer
okay who knows the answer to how often
the restaurant's cleaned if it's not you
I should know that you should know
better
you know Dina always comes out smelling
like a rose
Drilling
the register
it's always like that yeah that noisy
yeah the phone's worse
jeez
[Music]
e banana peppers thank you absolutely
Jesus way too much cheese for congealed
snot Sam this is what they'd normally be
like yes yeah yeah
wow strange
very very strange what do you think by
now I'm confused I mean I've never seen
anything like it I've never seen
you know Peppers stuff like that what's
happening they're frozen so when you put
them in the microwave and then you lift
them up all that water comes out yeah I
feel like I'm eating donkey's [__]
thank you Sam
wow now we've gone from bad to bizarre
you know what you wanna know what you
say about these ones what did he say
feels like he's eating a donkey's
pee-pee
because since he knows you froze them
all the crap comes out because there's
all that water in there
this is starting to get absurd Sam be
respectful
do you know this is Chef's chicken all
right I'm taking the Carlotta now
looking good looking good
chicken paralletta capellini this is the
okay great that's the dream sauce this
is the dream sauce
foreign
how do you think what a mess
how much garlic did you put in there
um I have no idea and the chicken why is
the chicken so hot it's like bullets
wow you've got to help them thank you
though you're welcome
brought together in a dream
Unfortunately they didn't realize that
time he was having a [__] nightmare
oh my God Dino what he said how much
garlic do you really put in this and I
said who knows and then a piece of the
could you get the chicken any dryer the
chicken and dryer
degree with what he had to say about my
chicken Carletta I prayed for months for
guidance and Mild Carlotta sauce is
inspired by God
all right come over guys
and this is like marker Mike yes sir
Nate nice uh I don't know where to start
I'm I'm lots of words
but what I will say is I think this is
the worst Italian food I've ever eaten
where shall I start the stuffed banana
peppers it was full of water Frozen
microwaves and then some bizarre weird
canned sauce the chicken Coletta chicken
was rubbery shredded chewed you didn't
like the sauce it was gross it was
garlicky it was just like something that
shouldn't have been put together in the
first place helped me to understand the
madness I got inspired by a higher power
a higher power John God I mean that God
made the sauce I mean you can't all be
there
can you guys go back in the kitchens
Dina Tina both that come over
when you can't even keep the place clean
that sends the alarm bells ringing
I think deep down inside you don't care
and you've stopped caring
that's not true really I do care Dino
talk to me I'm completely overwhelmed
who are you talking to any chance of
looking them in the eyes do you have a
pair of bollocks I'm over here I mean
I'm gonna stand there but just talk to
me uh what is the proper way to keep the
front of the house of the restaurant
are you embarrassed does your dad know
that you're this bad
take your father out of the equation
and you're [__]
we can't go on like this we need help
it's coming back I don't think he is
[Music]
after a very frightening first few hours
Chef Ramsay tracks down the man
responsible for funding levantes Tony hi
good Chef Dino and Tina's father Tony
I'm not the words I walked in there and
the first thing that hit me was the
animosity
and I'm nervous because I don't know if
I can help because those two don't care
okay but if it wasn't for your continued
financial support this business wouldn't
survive we were doing real good up to
about four or five years ago I kind of
blamed the economy more than anything
you know it's not the economy that's
affecting your restaurant now that's
that's not the economy well that's what
they're telling me anyway yeah
maybe they're telling you that so you
can keep funding it yeah right right how
much of the business are you
over over two hundred thousand two
hundred thousand just down to nothing
almost you know
must be heartbreaking yeah I fight with
my wife too and she started crying and
stuff like that
stand upside about it she's like just
close it up I don't want to hear this no
more you know
I'm really sorry I'm here for you I'm
going to get changed and I'll be in
there tonight thank you very much thank
you thank you Tony
[Music]
all right guys you ready all right let's
get this crap on the road as Chef
Ramsay's first observation of a dinner
service begins zucchini parm in a baked
rig of tongue he has made sure that he
is not the only one watching Dino and
Tina's performance I'll tell you how I
their father Tony is in the kitchen for
the first time in several months so this
is the line right yes yes sir uh how old
is that stove
50 years old the burners I have lit are
the only burners at work don't work at
all the evidence don't work no are you
kidding me no you're starting with that
what chance have you got
Dino this slip is sold
[Music]
there's that d
ude
uh no it's not oh my gosh Dino are you
actually Expediting I'm expediting
all you'll do is just lifting food from
that side of the kitchen and put it to
that side of the kitchen but I thought
you were Expediting I gotta kind of
asked Mike he's got enough to do any of
my food up uh hold on Hon hold on one
second
wow
it's yours but I think I think it's
three are mine despite the chaos in the
kitchen the servers somehow managed to
sort it out the pizza here and food is
making its way out to the diners knock
you unfortunately the speed of service
doesn't make up for the disappointing
flavor it's very chewy and gummy it
doesn't even look like meat this is
Alfredo sauce yes and it's a kind of
chunky it looks like if I could if I
throw something else
okay do you know
um they think the Alfredo is Lumpy
what's wrong with Adidas I don't think
he drained all of the what is that
Alfredo it's Alfredo that's a disgrace
okay your chicken tastes like it's
frozen and unfrozen oh no can you please
make me another one guys can you please
look at my fettuccine sauce look at that
it looks like curdled milk are you are
you kidding me no care nothing guys I
mean I just no wonder the food's coming
back
in the hell
stop stop
Dino urgently
that's the chicken we've been serving
all night yeah why is it sat and all
that look how slimy it is
oh my gosh how old is that oh my God
stop stop stop stop stop stop Tony two
seconds Tina you're part of this
what in the [__] are we doing how old is
that I don't know
look at the color of the chicken green
and stinking hold that
what's this
card in what
we're serving that
excuse me
look at the way we work what is this
what is this anybody I have no idea
you've got no idea and this how old's
this oh my God
disgusting pigs look at that
yeah it's fermented just just just smell
that
smell that
come on please you own it
ladies we've been serving that see them
all around the side oh my God oh my God
I thought that was basil oh my God no
that's not basil I wish it was [__]
basil how long does a sauce sit in the
fridge to get moldy around the top quite
a quite a long time
I didn't expect to see all this they're
not doing a job they're supposed to be
doing and these guys they're gonna have
a rough time now this is the town of
beaver deserve this absolutely not you
should be ashamed I ashamed
now walk out there and apologize to your
guests and try and do something you've
never done in 14 years [__] work
together
[Music]
let's go
excuse me
um we we appreciate you guys coming out
here and and trying out our a restaurant
tonight but uh we won't be having any
more Service uh Chef frenzy has shut us
down for the evening
[__] how
oh guys guys thank you
[Music]
Dino you're telling them that I'm
shutting it down
I was just I heard you I was standing
behind the door
Chef Ramsay did not shut this down I
stopped the owners from serving [__]
food
but I am not going to continue that
because you don't realize right now
young man how bad you've become
so I'm not shutting it down
I'm just stopping you looking more
stupid
did you honestly want to continue
serving
so you want to continue
you you wanna you wanna continue serving
[Music]
hi ladies and gentlemen can I just have
your attention for 30 seconds
oh gosh he has it is
[Music]
after Chef Ramsay discovered rotten
chicken look how slimy it is and moldy
sauce the disgusting pigs Dino and Tina
blame the shutdown of the restaurant on
Chef Ramsay's shutters down Dino you're
telling them that I'm shutting it down
and now Chef Ramsay is determined to
give a more accurate explanation ladies
and gentlemen can I just have your
attention for 30 seconds first of all
my apologies but I'm not going to BS
anybody
I am not shutting this restaurant down I
am stopping the owners serving this
disgusting mess from chicken that's
already slimed off gone it's a
disgusting basil that was never fresh
to a tomato sauce there's actually caked
in mold I am not gonna sit here
and play Party to that
I mean birds and whilst I I'm totally
appreciative for you leaving your homes
to come here tonight for dinner I've got
too much respect for you and too much
respect for the industry I am not
going to be part of this any longer my
sincere apologies
[Music]
seriously well what do we do comp
everything
I'm very very pissed off radar it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing
no wonder they complain out there now I
know exactly why this place wasn't
making any money
[Music]
[__]
all right
I'm embarrassed I'm sorry absolutely
listen I am so freaking sorry let me
tell you but those two need to know how
bad they've become I'm not going to
continue selling food like that I don't
blame you I don't want people to come
here for that no
I wouldn't want to eat that [__] either
you know I see what's going on and I'm
sick of it these kids got a lot of work
to do they've given up
work my ass off all my life
good job
Hey listen I'm here for you I'm gonna do
everything I can to get this business
turned around but I need you okay you
got me
I'm gonna get involved I'm not gonna
make it easy for nobody okay
[Music]
while Chef Ramsay is disappointed with
Dino and Tina he remains in the town of
beaver to support Tony I turn who has
been blindsided by his children's lack
of commitment okay this is gonna be the
most important meeting with your son and
daughter since you've opened that
business they need to fight for the jobs
I need to understand you are the boss
yeah
you ready
tough love my kids better change I will
close the restaurant and they're both
gonna be hot
truthfully I don't think both of you
know how easy you've had it you're
fighting against each other as opposed
to fighting for the future of the
business
I gave you a chance both the units you
guys never did what you're supposed to
do you know
those things have to stop arguing
otherwise you're not going to get
nothing out of their business I'll sell
the building I'll close it up and Neons
are not going to get nothing out of it
I gotta be dead
for you to get anything
well then I'm sorry
for letting you down
I promise and I'm will make you proud
once you guys work on I will work and do
whatever necessary to get a restaurant
going again
I I first let me just apologize that for
everything that we've been through for
the last couple of years I thought I
knew what problems we had and I had no
idea
that I didn't know and if you give me
another opportunity I promise you from
the bottom of my heart that I am 100
committed
foreign
I'm giving you guys a chance you guys
better work together you now
with all of your slaves more than ever
before because tomorrow
we are relaunching your father's
restaurant and I want to see both of you
ready to work my team alongside the
research that I've been doing we've been
looking at what's not available in
Beaver County and based on that research
let me tell you levantes needs a
dramatic change levantes is going to
become an American Bistro
see bright and early in the morning
thank you Chef see you in the morning
thank you see in the morning get ready
for change thank you Chef I agree with
Chef Ramsay things needed to change and
uh I think all of us are extremely
excited about the new levantes Bistro
[Music]
coming up you guys are starting to make
me look like an idiot it's a relaunch
night filled with drama you're falling
behind and emotion you screw up this is
going to be the end it's not only Dino
and Tina's last chance I'm confused it's
the restaurants as well oh come on guys
wake up a little bit
faced with a restaurant that hasn't been
touched in 15 years Chef Ramsay and his
team have their hands full as they
transform levantes from an Italian
restaurant into a modern American Bistro
rice good morning good morning how are
we good we're good are you ready to see
a stunning new restaurant yes yes chef
okay take off your blindfolds
[Music]
new levantes your American Bistro oh my
God oh my gosh that's awesome oh wow
gone are those dark and dreary walls
take a look how new and modern how
appealing it is
we got rid of those horrendous filthy
booths we're placing the new chairs new
table tops and a brand new Central
seating area
thank you so much I haven't smiled in
here for a long time and I can't seem to
stop I'm so happy thank you so much Jeff
now one more thing during my first meal
I couldn't even concentrate on my food
it sounded like a construction site with
this thing
hammering around
shaking away so I'd like to introduce
you to a stunning who our system oh my
God yay that's so cool from POS lavu and
cephyr Hardware it is easy to use it's
wireless and it can be operated anywhere
in this building get out this is The
Cutting Edge of POS systems it will
truly help in terms of purchasing your
fixed costs and your profits that's cool
oh yes that's cool we're gonna have a
new beginner and it's this is this is
just awesome
I told you day one I'm here to support
you
so I have found you two consultants and
they run two very successful restaurants
one of them is listed in the top 25
restaurants in Pittsburgh Avenue B I'd
like to introduce the chef Chris onvilly
and his wife general manager Jen Von
Philly Chris how are you sir I'm doing
well good to see you are you well yeah I
am Jen how are you my darling welcome
good to see you Chris is going to
orchestrate with a kitchen and Jen is
going to help set up
the dining room we're happy to come in
and just do what we do and make awesome
food so that's what we're talking about
they are here on a consultant basis so
you need to listen and take that level
of expertise and put it into this
restaurant and pass that knowledge down
to your team
Tony Dina Tina I've got one more little
surprise for you guys come with me thank
you
welcome
for your new kitchen
[Music]
first of all when I arrived this kitchen
was so dilapidated I wouldn't even
attempt to cook anything from there let
me tell you so I made some rather urgent
calls to my friends at color equip and I
asked them to put together a line of
brand new equipment let's start off with
an amazing energy efficient Falcon six
burner range top of the lime
when I say top of the range I'm talking
top of the range
a griddle top underneath that it has a
broiler underneath that it has two ovens
next to that you've got a two basket
fryer from pitco opposite that an
amazing brand new steam table from Eagle
group and then this
for me is the Rolls-Royce a state of the
Arts logic brush stainless steel
convection oven this blodges holds five
baking trays it's amazing Chef you now
have all the tools to run this as a
successful Russian let me tell you
there's no excuse
cheers
now that levantes has been converted
into a Contemporary American Bistro
excellent come through please
Chef Ramsay continues his plan by
introducing a brand new menu to match
we're cooking American Classics looks
good looks beautiful let's start off
with the corn bisque sweet corn done
beautifully seasoned and serve with
little fritters awesome next to that
we've got mussels done with pancetta
shallots garlic white wine butter
classic entrees starting off with the
braised lamb shank Brazil vegetables red
wine and a really nice lamb stock and
that will just fall off the bone yeah
it's tremendous and then finally pan
seared salmon with barley salad rice
fennel and pancetta with fresh herbs
nobody has a menu like this locally now
you can stand out from the competition I
think everything looks so good here good
anybody hungry yeah yeah good get some
knife and forks dig in
[Music]
oh my God that is good it is delicious
amazing food amazing I think we can
compete now amazing oh I know you eat it
all I just love it
tastes good
it's relaunch night at levantes but
before they open for business Tony has a
little business of his own
tonight you gotta promise me that you
guys gonna work hard and make this
happen entire game with you guys gave a
new giving you you're gonna you guys
gonna give back to me believe me I
understand you don't have to tell me
again down commit it I promise it should
be because I'll tell you what if you
guys don't you screw up this is going to
be the end
what's that I got it we're on it so much
pressure this evening but I met what I
said I'm gonna work hard and Earnest
trust back I'm gonna be watching you
guys
with the pressure clearly on levantes
opens its doors to the town of Beaver
Pennsylvania for the first time as an
American Bistro
good evening folks welcome follow me
please
I'll have the New York strip wow that's
really high tech heck yeah we aren't
playing around anymore with Chris
guiding Dino in the kitchen crab cake
dip crab is in our hands right now
selling you two dips and Jen working
with Tina in the dining room you could
always cap the end of that four top the
relaunch is off to a smooth start wow I
can't believe this is the same clothes
what's this I'm confused I don't have
the slip
checks on the printer Chef check on the
printer got a stack of checks up there
yeah I know I got to get I got I have a
stack right here at this Pole right now
[Music]
table number please sorry table number
51. thank you Dino is pretty rough at
running the pass uh he's pretty timid I
think he's not so sure of himself he's
having a hard time kind of grabbing the
reins and getting after it container get
on top of it gotta work three or four
tables at once you're getting confused
with tickets look at me yeah you're
falling behind get on top of it please
we're in the [__] now let's go
[Music]
can I get a Time on table one please 71
appetizer how much longer for table
three they've been waiting a really long
time did I already give that to you
are you kidding me Dino needs to get his
stuff together or else we're gonna be an
embarrassment once again to the entire
Community yeah no we're in the [__] now
let's go
I got this table 43 been waiting here
over an hour for food 43 18 or 43 what's
going on they've been here for an hour
table 43. I feel like we've we sold that
I really hope that Dino catch some quick
because if you screw up the first time
I'll give you the second chance
you screw up the second chin you're done
with me okay look stop Dino Fire season
43 has not gone out
oh guys
it's an hour into the relaunch of
levantes and Dino has lost control of
the kitchen table 43 I feel like we sold
that that stop Dino
43 has not gone out Dino jump the
tickets okay jump the tickets what we've
got to handle that one first Chris can
you stop what you're doing for five
minutes join it by the sides Dino wake
up a little bit you need to own it let's
go if I'm waiting on a burger medium to
sell then my next order I'm looking for
salmon midwell burger midwell I realized
tonight how much I do need Chris's help
I have a mountain of learning ahead of
me it's just going to take a little bit
of time for me Table Three yes Burger
Hallelujah check Soul a burger you're
welcome I'll come back and check on you
enjoy
firing table four muscles butcher's
board Dino has a ton to learn at this
point but he has an awesome opportunity
here and he's the one that has to to
make it happen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
loved the American Bistro did you hear
the feedback from the food I didn't have
a single complaint tonight Tina did a
great job Dino tonight you've had a
first grasp of what it's really like
running the fort yeah I did and it's not
Chris and Jen ran your restaurants
you've got to stick with them you've got
to listen to them a big thank you to
them both because I thought you did an
amazing job thank you very much
well done good night guys uh good job
Tony two minutes
listen that was a tough day I had such a
good time you did yes everybody loved it
and it's good to see you smiling
you have a town now that is in love with
your wrestler again you can walk out
those doors and hold your head up behind
me I can thank you
enough you're a special father let me
tell you there's not many about
take care Captain thank you yeah good to
see you love to the family
okay I'm gonna listen to you good night
good night take care
when I came to Beaver Pennsylvania I had
no idea that this would be one of the
biggest kitchen nightmare
Transformations ever but there's still
two very big question marks remain one's
Dino and the second one's Tina will they
finally step up and satisfy not just the
father but their customers too this is a
very close-knit town and
I guess we'll just have to Leave It to
Beaver
wow
in the weeks that followed and table one
Janae good evening how you doing Chris
and Jen continued their training of Dino
and Tina they need to see you hustling
too they're going to hustle as much as
you hustle and with brother and sister
working well together how's everything
going it's going okay I was coming to
check on you Tony can rest a bit easier
knowing that his children are in control
and that the future of levantes looks
great all right let's do it
[Music]
foreign